firefighters are working around the
clock to battle an outbreak of wildfires
from the Pacific coast down to Arizona
and into the Rocky Mountains of Colorado
a fast-moving wildfire is threatening
the mountain resort town a Breckenridge
Colorado and hundreds of people have
been forced to evacuate there David beg
no is in Breckenridge with the latest
efforts to fight this fire David good
morning good morning Gail let me show
you what's fueling this fire it's dry
brush like this when you hear it snap
with no moisture you realize why that's
like a match for a wildfire 500 homes
have been evacuated a lot of people
affected are here on vacation scared to
death quite frankly yesterday it all
started when a guy on a mountain bike
headed up a trail saw the fire called
9-1-1
they hiked firefighters and they
parachuted others and within a very
short period of time the flames were a
hundred and twenty-five feet high and
that's why authorities here in
Breckenridge blew the whistle as fire
crews here in Colorado try to beat back
the quickly spreading wildfire known as
Pete two officials here are worried
about the dry timber that's feeding it
trees do burn especially dead trees so
it certainly helps to fuel you know a
fire starting out as 50 by 50 going to
82 acres in a matter of six or seven
hours the Wildfire exploded inside White
River National Forest on Wednesday
throwing smoke high into the air and
forcing hundreds of evacuations putting
the town of Breckenridge on notice the
fire really didn't move too quick until
about one o'clock it started to move
about 1:30 to 2:00 o'clock the fire
really blew up well that's a pretty big
chain people inside the peak 7
neighborhood which is about 3 miles from
the fire line we're told to pack their
belongings I had no idea this was going
on I was out working in the yard came
around the corner and they said you're
supposed to be out of here knowing how
dry it is we were very concerned about
it and called 911
mark Rosen Kerr is on vacation here he's
also a CBS News Transportation Safety
analyst
all day we've been seeing it but what
we've also seen of course is an
incredible coordination and incredible
work done by the firefighters we've had
hotshot
come we've had smokejumpers coming in
we've had two aerial tankers come we've
had a number of helicopters come and
drop water on it Jeff the fire is
burning about a mile behind me but it's
deceiving because you've got snow on the
mountaintop at the highest peak and the
fire burning in the middle it's cold
right now but when the Sun comes out
things will heat up but make no mistake
about it the winds will dictate whether
or not it's another dangerous day here
in the Rockies